[Music]  occasionally our staff members bring  their kids to work and what happens at a  lot of workplaces but I just love it the  kids are always very cute and I love  meeting them so I thought it might be  fun to ask our staff members kids what  their parents think about working for me  and well once again it's time for  staffers kids say the darndest things  [Applause]  did your mom like having Conan as a boss  no she said Conan should have a horrible  disease named after him does your dad  like having Conan as a boss after  working there he doesn't believe in God  anymore  Conan gave my mom five thousand dollars  and told her it was time to buy some new  presses one time Conan throw hot coffee  in my dad's eyes and now he can't see  and quorum calls him blind emic no sight  you  you